I think the overarching motif of this
week is none of the rides are what we
were expected yeah well I mean we kind
of we followed the river down to the
ocean and that's one maybe a little more
than halfway we started we can come into
healthy ocean and by the time we got
there and it dropped at least 10 degrees
we're all kind of working pretty hard
even to go downhill shivering a little
and then as we came around had a nice
nice big climb
it was it was heart it's a lot of work
cruising back through some years in
canyons
moving really fast so John Bradley
brother you see my selfie
crank advanced really last
I keep thinking two down two to go the
weather's been wonderful and kind of
being out here on the river is great and
writing every day is great but it's not
not punishing